Jaakko I'm leading a project that
involves a few my team members and about
10 other team members from other
functions the project has high
visibility in the large organization
over 10 billion in revenue that I work
for so the pressures to execute is high
we have had some issues with
cross-functional team members meeting
their deliverables and keeping them to
keep the project on path but we're
pushing sometimes dragging everyone
along to make things happen recently on
a formal review with the leadership team
the question was asked why is this
project behind I'm a firm believer in
providing protection for your team so my
response was there are excuses but to be
honest they're just excuses so we're
doing everything we can to get it back
on track trying to take the brunt of the
performance mists on my shoulders no
additional comments were made in that
meeting and it ended my boss was on the
call and pulled me aside the next day
and voiced his opinion that I should not
hesitate to call out the lack of
performance on the other functional team
members his thought is that doing so
does not allow the leadership to coach
mentor and/or fix the issues correctly I
understand this logic but I don't feel
that true leaders point fingers or throw
others under the bus your thoughts would
be appreciated ok so first of all your
boss has a little bit of a point but
it's but it's also there's some
limitations to it number one you know
our goal as a leader is to build
relationships with people accomplish the
mission etc etc so if if we if we start
just calling people out in front of a
senior leadership on a call well are you
forming a good relationship with people
the answer's no you're actually making
them mad and they're saying the first
thing you're gonna do when you call them
out it's called call you up as soon as
the call ends and they're gonna say dude
why don't you tell me that why you
telling me this in front of the boss so
here's the deal you should not ever have
to throw someone under the bus without
plenty of warning right without plenty
of them to know and expect and be
prepared with an answer that's what you
should be doing it's kind of like that
escalation of counseling when I talk
about like you start off by just saying
hey man you were late you know what's up
and you go all the way to like okay if
you're late again and there's a whole
slow escalation or depending on how fast
you need to get it done but with this
one it's the same thing you say hey echo
you know you're part of the project what
do you need help right now what's going
on you don't seem up to speed and then
it then we escalate to hey echo you just
missed another you know target date this
is the second target date you've missed
we get weird a problem and then it's hey
echo do you not have the sports you need
what do you need cuz this isn't working
out
and then it's look the only way I'm
gonna be able to do this we gotta bring
us up to the boss I think you need more
people and then that's another important
thing is is you frame it you frame it in
such a way that it's not hurting them
but it's actually helping them so I
might say on the call hey you know Alpha
Team is working really hard but they
need more XY and Z to get the job done
so you know I think we should give echo
and Alpha Team more XY and Z okay
because he missed a date and and I know
they're working hard or you say you know
I think we need more people allocated
over to Alpha Team I think they've been
over tasked and they could use some
support so let's give them some more
people or you can even say I'm moving
two people from my team over to Alpha
Team temporarily to give them some
additional capacity over there because
their task is more demanding than what
I've been assigned hmm
so all of those things are letting
everyone know bringing the problem to
the attention of the of the group so
that now you say actually jaakko here's
what's going on I don't need two more
people I need four more people
hmm or you know you say okay um hey I
don't need anyone else if you're one of
those people the ego gets in the way I
don't need anyone else and he'll say
okay well you missed two time marks you
missed two you know
dates well I don't need any more people
okay okay well let's see if you can if
you can make this next date then I guess
you don't but if you miss another date
well then I guess you need more people
mm-hmm so we move through it like that
so yeah you do have to discuss things
you can do you can discuss these things
you can bring them up in a way that they
are not offensive to two people they
don't throw them under the bus but they
do however is signify
that the bus is around and that if we
aren't careful you might get hit by the
bus and you've got to give people plenty
of warning it's the same thing with same
thing I've talked about in the past with
skipping the chain of command you know
you shouldn't be skipping the chain of
command unless unless you've given so
much warning and you do it in such a way
that you know vague they actually know
what's gonna happen they expect is gonna
happen they kind of agree with you so be
careful with those things again if
someone's doing something immoral
illegal unethical and you skip the chain
of command cuz you've already tried to
solve them and they're not doing it well
then you might have to just go get some
because if you're Koval if you don't
yeah so form good relationships and
people don't form antagonistic
relationships you know I just had a
conversation with a guy when I was in in
Boston similar situation but you know he
he was saying he there was a situation
he was in and what he said was
politically it was he didn't want to
address it because politically if he'd
rested it might explode and I said well
if the if at address if you address the
situation there's like a classic case I
know how to do this more efficiently
this experienced person doesn't want to
try my method okay and I said well why
don't you present him with the method
and say you know hey here's here's how
we should do this and he says no I don't
want to do that because the person that
I want to get to use the new method is
really close friends with the boss and
even if I form that bad relationship
it's gonna be bad and I go would that
affect your overall mission to your
ability to do the mission to have bad
relationships not only with your
immediate boss blow through your boss's
boss and he's like yes it would and I go
then doesn't sound like a good plan
there you go there's your answer because
even though you have a better method and
you might say like a direct person with
a direct train of thought mindset would
say no you go you tell the boss's boss
that this is the method and we're gonna
be more efficient if we do it this way
well now you've just exploded a bomb on
yourself
and it's gonna be bad so I gave him the
classic hey why don't you say listen I
think I've thought of a new method I
think we might be able to get some
efficiencies out of it but since I'm not
as experienced and don't know the
system's as well as you do I would love
to get your feedback
how it works I think that you're the
only one that could really know how to
do this consider so experienced and
smart and brilliant all that stuff and
awesome and you try and feed him some of
the new methods so that he can try it
and meters say yeah this stuff's pretty
good or you know what there's some
things that you didn't realize Young
Buck and we got to get them fixed yeah
so check try and form relationships
positive relationships not antagonistic
relationships
if you throw people under the bus you're
not forming good relationships check
especially that surprised one that's
rough mmm yeah